morning more than 300 nurses nurses and
supporters gathered outside of a
henderson hospital
they say they don't have the right gear
to safely do their job
bianca holmen has the story nurses here
are frustrated saying they lack the
proper personal protective equipment to
care for the sick
this morning these health care workers
protested outside of saint rose
dominican
they claim they're forced to wear one
time used ppe
all day and not enough supply is stopped
on each floor
nurses also say there isn't enough staff
and communication from leadership
is poor zachary pritchett is an icu
nurse
i work in the intensive care unit where
nurses normally staff
between one and two patients and right
now we're working
and taking care of three patients a
piece and when you take care of three
patients
it's very hard to give adequate
attention to those patients in those
critical settings
as far as morale in the hospital goes i
think a lot of the staff
feel completely forgotten and abandoned
by our leadership
saint rose dominican leadership sent us
a statement on complaints from nurses
it says nurses working additional shifts
and in critical care areas are
compensated with incentive pay
we also continue to work with traveling
nurse agencies to secure available
staffing resources to safely
cover shifts as needed in regards to ppe
they state we provide appropriate ppe to
every staff member
working in our hospital and have gone to
great lengths to ensure we have
adequate supplies for all of our staff
and clinicians
nurses say they'll continue to make
their demands heard and care for their
patients
reporting from henderson bianca holman 8
news now